un buen día para los latinoamericanos
aquí en la tokyo 2020 con richard cara
paz el ecuatoriano quien ganó su primera
medalla de oro en la prueba de ciclismo
de ruta tras ganar esta prueba de 234
kilómetros en el circuito internacional
de fuji una prueba muy difícil con seis
ascensos el ecuatoriano sus 28 años
bueno se dio a la fuga a unos 5
kilómetros de la llegada y cruzó la
línea de meta en solitario en 6 horas y
05 minutos eso fue el tiempo que le
bastó para llevarse este título olímpico
con la plata pues fue el belga wood
habana que se quedó con la plata y el
bronce fue para el esloveno tadej
agachar también otra presea esta vez la
número 70 en la historia las
participaciones mexicanas en los juegos
olímpicos fue para el tiro con arco en
equipo son mixtos para los mexicanos
alejandra valencia y luís álvarez quien
lograron llevarse el bronce tras vencer
a turquía este domingo habrá un partido
muy esperado es el comienzo del rating
de eeuu en ambas
se enfrentará a francia y también pues
la entrada lista de dos de los nuevos
deportes olímpicos el surf y el
skateboard